in this course you will learn to create
an android app using the jetpack compose
ui library
along the way you will learn about graph
algorithms and data structures ryan mk
teaches this course he is a very
experienced developer and instructor
what's up everybody this is ryan here
and i would like to welcome you to my
tutorial series on the graph sudoku
application this is an application i
wrote primarily to refine my
understanding of graph data structures
and algorithms and the new ui library on
android jetpack compose in this part of
the series i will overview the main
goals and topics of the series and
discuss a few design decisions which may
come as a surprise to you i will try to
keep the public version of the project
source code up to date and it will be
your responsibility to look at that
source code if something becomes
deprecated or stops working
the format of this series is a code
along style which implies that the best
way to learn is to write the code with
me as i explain it for advanced
developers the full source is available
for direct learning but you can watch
the videos to clear up any holes in your
knowledge
i use some fairly advanced features of
the kotlin language and the timeless
principles of software architecture so
you might learn a thing or two for
beginners it is very important that you
follow along with me in code but at your
own pace
you might not feel like you are making
progress at first but understand that
you'll be practicing the skill of
writing code even if you don't yet
understand what you're writing i will
also secretly be teaching you how to
write code which is easy to write read
fix improve and test
but instead of asking you to memorize
the timeless principles of software
design you will learn and use them in
practice as we build this application
there are four general topics that this
tutorial will demonstrate graph data
structures and algorithms jetpack
compose clean gui architectures and
kotlin language features
we will explore the topic of directed
colored graphs and my experiments in
writing algorithms to generate solve and
unsolve n sized sudoku puzzles we will
build the entire user interface using
jetpack compose which allows us to
create our ui entirely in kotlin as
opposed to xml views and styles
i will show you how to wire up a simple
app using principles commonly expounded
in solid and clean architectures however
i teach these topics in my own way so do
not expect a bunch of jargon or over
engineering
i will also demonstrate how and when to
use basic and advanced features of this
beautiful programming language this part
of the video is intended more for
intermediate and advanced developers
understanding this design decision is
not required to complete the tutorial
throughout this tutorial you will notice
that apart from compose and proto
datastore i use almost no libraries from
android jetpack in fact very few
third-party libraries in general by
relying on kotlin and java's standard
libraries and the android sdk my code
becomes more resistant to deprecations
and changes in libraries this is because
the android sdk and the standard
libraries tend to change less frequently
than third-party libraries such as those
you see in android jetpack it also means
that some things which libraries like
jetpack view model jetpack navigation or
hilt might handle must be hand written
by us i actually like that but you might
have a different value system and my
goal here is not to discourage you from
learning these tools if you are
interested in them with that being said
you might be surprised at how easy it is
to write your own view model navigation
or dependency injection code without
them in a small app like this one
this application uses model view
whatever architecture which is my way of
saying that i don't follow anyone else's
style
having studied this topic for many years
i let the project requirements and my
understanding of the principles of good
software design guide my architecture
in this case i find that compose is made
for an mvvm based approach but i added a
presentation logic class for a specific
reason this reason is called passive
view or humble object instead of having
the view or the view model manage the
control flow of each screen i pull that
logic into a separate class this class
is super easy to write and test because
it has no third party dependencies and
it prevents my view model from becoming
an ugly god object you should try it
sometime i designed this architecture
simply by applying the single most
important principle of software
architecture separation of concerns
that's it for this part of the series
now we begin coding
the domain package represents two things
the most general pieces of information
such as data classes constants and enums
which the program must virtually
represent
also the most general things this
program must do
which the program represents using
functions and interfaces
in essence it is the foundation of any
new program i write and i use a
repeatable process to design my domain
package or module for a clear and simple
introduction to that process check out
this video on my channel how to design
information systems and applications
that video is a recording of a talk i
gave to some software engineers
in egypt about that particular topic
anyways most of the code in this package
is simple but it does include a design
pattern which i will introduce now
this package contains several interfaces
which are used to employ the repository
design pattern this pattern is also
known as the facade pattern and the
general goal of the pattern is simpler
than its technical definition
the technical definition of the facade
repository pattern is to hide the
details of a subsystem in this case data
storage mechanisms behind an abstraction
in this case an interface
let's look at a practical example to
make sense out of that definition
our presentation logic classes will hold
references to these repository
interfaces instead of the classes which
implement the interfaces
this gives several benefits to our
presentation logic classes they can be
built independently of each other
without causing a compiler error
they can be tested with a fake
implementation of the interface without
requiring us to change any code within
the presentation logic class
also if we decide to use a different
implementation of the interface such as
switching from file storage to a room
database we can also do that without
requiring any changes to the
presentation logic class
these benefits are a result of building
software systems which are loosely
coupled and the repository or facade
pattern is an easy way to promote loose
coupling in fact interfaces in general
tend to promote loose coupling now don't
feel the need to use this pattern
everywhere
a good general rule is to use them in
significant architectural boundaries in
this case i am using them as a boundary
between the front end and the back end
of this application
to start things off right click on the
domain package
go to new
kotlin file
and create a file called
difficulty
and that's going to be an enum class
enum classes in kotlin and java and
various other languages are useful for
creating a restricted set of values as
we'll see later on you can use sealed
classes in kotlin to create a restricted
set of types in any case the main
benefit outside of just creating that
set of restricted values is that enums
can greatly improve the legibility of
your program as we'll see in a moment
let's add in our enum entries
quite obviously this enum will represent
the difficulty of a given sudoku puzzle
however we need to add one more thing
before moving on we will actually be
using some values for each of these
entries in the algorithms to basically
dictate the difficulty of the sudoku
puzzle so in order to add a value to
an enum in kotlin we need to give it a
property or some properties
as you can see our entries are now red
so obviously we need to give them some
doubles
and that's everything we need to do here
right click on the main package go to
new kotlin file or class
and we're going to create a data class
called settings
settings is our first data model as i
like to call it or a plain old kotlin
object and as we'll see in a moment it
will contain both the difficulty and the
boundary which is the size of the sudoku
puzzle so a four by four sudoku puzzle
will have a boundary of four a nine by
nine will have a boundary of nine
the data keyword when put ahead of a
class keyword basically adds or
generates a couple of helper methods
such as equals hash code or copy uh
we'll definitely be making use of copy
later on maybe not in this class but in
some of them and at a certain point we
will also make use of the generated
hashcode function
anyways this is a really simple class
we're just going to add two properties
to it
and that's it
right click on the domain package
go to new kotlin class or file and this
time we're going to create a class
called user statistics and that's going
to be a data class
now the purpose of this class is to
represent the user's
shortest slash best times for solving
any particular difficulty or size of
sudoku puzzle so we're basically just
going to add a whole bunch of properties
that are pretty much the same
now one thing you can do in intellij
idea or android studio is you can just
click there and then hit control d
however many times you need and that
will copy to a new line
[Music]
that's basically it for this class now
you might be wondering why are we using
long here we're actually storing the
time
it takes for the user to complete a
particular game in milliseconds so
that's why we want the long integer
value
again right click on the domain package
go to new kotlin filer class and this is
going to be a data class named sudoku
node
now this is where things start to get a
little more complicated and interesting
with our data models so what i'm doing
here is i'm representing an individual
node in a graph data structure we're
going to talk a lot more about graph
data structures later on when we get to
the part of the tutorial dedicated to it
but just to give you an idea
so we are actually going to be building
a directed colored graph and an
important thing here to note is that in
this particular case this term color
really just refers to a number it's just
a value we associate
in some kind of node and again to give
you a preview ahead when i say graph
data structure a better name for it
would be a
network data structure because that's
essentially what it is it's a collection
of nodes
and edges which are essentially like
lines between the nodes relationships
between the nodes
anyways this particular node structure
in our data structure
is going to have a color or a value
which is just an integer from 1 through
nine or one to four also including zero
zero represents like an empty sudoku
tile but that's more concern of the
front end
these nodes will also include an x and y
coordinates so the top left will be x
zero y 0 the bottom right will be x 8
y 8
and we're going to be using 0 based
indexing so instead of starting from x 1
to x 9 we just basically subtract that
by 1.
so that's it for that preamble let's get
started writing the code
so we'll start with the x and y values
next we will add the color which will be
a variable because it can change
throughout the course of execution
then we will add a boolean called read
only and i'll explain what that is after
we write it
now the purpose of the read-only boolean
here is quite simple
when we essentially generate and then
unsolve a sudoku puzzle which is another
way of saying we create a new sunoku
puzzle then remove a certain number of
clues to make the game actually playable
and fun
some of those numbers on the sudoku
board or in the sudoku graph data
structure will be read only those are
like the given clues that the user is
not supposed to be able to change
themselves
as we'll see later on this will also
affect the user interface because we
will draw the read-only sudoku nodes or
tiles differently than the ones which
the user can edit
now we're not quite done yet we need to
override the hashcode function which was
provided by the data class keyword as i
discussed earlier and then we also need
to add a function to get a hashcode
okay so hashcode will have a default
implementation which is based on the
values provided up here in the different
properties we're actually just going to
do something different so we're going to
type
get
hash
like that
and this is actually a function that we
are going to create also we'll add in
two parameters here for x and y
okay we're now going to add the get hash
function and it's going to be top level
which means it sits outside the brackets
of our sudoku node class
okay let's just implement this function
and then i'll explain what we're doing
here
okay so let me start by explaining what
exactly a hash code or hash value is so
it's essentially some kind of generated
key or unique identifier based on some
kind of algorithm in this case i have a
very simple algorithm all i do is
multiply the x value by 100 and i leave
the y value alone and i basically just
combine those two values together into
an integer
now the reason why i multiply x by 100
is if i didn't do that in a nine by nine
sudoku puzzle there would be certain
edge cases where the even though the x
and y value are technically different
the resulting hash code would
not be unique for several different
nodes
simply put i'm multiplying by a hundred
to make the hash codes unique for every
individual tile in the sudoku puzzle
as for why we're using hashcode in
general i'll try and keep it fairly
straightforward basically we're going to
be storing each node in the graph in a
linked hash map so the hash values will
represent the key for that hashmap a
hashmap has key value pairs in case
you're not aware we'll be seeing that in
a moment but this turns out to be really
useful because our user interface as
well will be representing things in that
kind of x and y coordinate style
so just take my word for it hash codes
are pretty handy in situations where you
have a large number of elements and you
don't necessarily want to have to
maintain a reference for every
individual element
instead we can just retrieve a reference
by getting a hash code
oh and before we go we need to add one
more thing here we're going to make this
thing implement serializable
now essentially what this does is it
allows us to read and write our sudoku
nodes and also the whole puzzle to a
file since we're only going to be
storing one puzzle at a time i didn't
really want to use something like a
database it kind of just made more sense
to use the file system and serializable
makes it easier to do that essentially
okay we have one final data model to
create in this particular package again
right click
new kotlin filer class
this one's going to be called sudoku
puzzle and again it's going to be a data
class
a good way to think of data models as i
like to call them
is that they are virtual representations
of a real world object in this case a
sudoku puzzle
the way that i initially designed this
class is by asking critical questions
about what constitutes a sudoku puzzle
things like the boundary so are there
four tiles per row or column or are
there nine tiles for example we have the
difficulty and most importantly we have
the graph data structure itself there's
also the elapsed time which the user has
taken to solve a particular puzzle
so let's go ahead and add those
properties in and then i'll explain some
of them the ones that need to be
explained afterwards
also before i forget let's add in the
serializable implementation here
okay so you're probably wondering what
build new sudoku is
so what we'll be doing is we're actually
going to be calling a large series of
top-level functions which will form all
of our different algorithms which are
necessary to build and generate a new
sudoku puzzle based on a given size
which is what boundary represents and a
given difficulty
also if you're wondering about what's
going on with the linked hash map which
is full of linked lists that's kind of a
way of representing an adjacency list
again i'm going to go into those details
on graph data structures and different
ways you can represent them or at least
how i represent them in this particular
application later when we get to that
particular package and topic
but for the time being understand this
represents our virtual sudoku puzzle the
last thing we're going to do is just add
in a small little method which just
makes it a little more obvious and
legible how to get a hold of the graph
itself at least in my opinion
and we're going to use single expression
syntax so i'm just going to type equals
graph
let's create a new interface called i
game repository
i like to use this naming convention of
putting a capital i in front of the
interfaces
and then as we'll see later on in the
persistence package i will add a suffix
of impl which stands for implementation
to naturally the classes which implement
this interface
when designing a small to medium scale
application one thing you can do is you
can actually conceptually think of the
functions in your repository interfaces
as use cases themselves the things we're
going to be writing here are going to be
called like save game update game update
node which is very similar if you're
doing like a user stories in the use
cases type application design so i just
wanted to throw that in there in a more
complicated application where i needed
to do more coordination of multiple
different data sources and repositories
i probably would have like an interactor
or a use case as it's commonly talked
about between martin fowler or robert
martin uncle bob
but in this particular case in simpler
applications generally speaking the use
case as a class itself
is typically an unnecessary extra layer
of abstraction so with here we're just
going with our presenter or viewmodel or
whatever talking directly to a
repository and that is a sufficient
amount of abstraction for an application
of this size
now how an interface works is that it's
very similar to a class except as we'll
see in a moment we're not actually
allowed to implement or give a
body to the functions that we'll be
writing we just write what are commonly
called either abstract functions or
function stubs
now there's two important points here
firstly the suspend keyword is applied
there because
these functions will actually be called
from co-routine scopes which exist in
the logic class or the presenter that
will be referencing this particular
interface so that's all we need to do to
establish concurrency for now
now in case you're not familiar what i'm
using here is what's known as a function
type
and so what we'll do is we will be
actually passing in a reference to two
functions which exist in the logic class
the presentation logic
will pass those functions in and then in
the repository implementations the
things which implement this particular
interface that is how they will call
back with some kind of result either a
successful result or a failure now you
might be wondering why do we have unit
and then it returns unit which is what
that arrow means in this particular case
this is something we kind of have to do
in order for the kotlin compiler to
understand exactly what we're telling it
to do so this would be kind of
equivalent to passing in void or like
basically nothing into this particular
function and then returning nothing from
that particular function but what it
will do is it will signal something like
an on complete if you have any
experience with rxjava we're basically
we just want to resume the application
successfully when this function is
called but this particular function does
not actually need to return anything
later on we'll see some examples of when
we actually need to return a value
through our onsuccess function type
again you might be wondering what is the
difference between saving a game and
updating a game well essentially in the
update game function we're going to be
wholesale writing an entire sudoku
puzzle which includes an elapsed time
although there are some situations where
all we really need to do is simply
update the elapsed time of the game such
as when the user navigates away from the
application so what i'm doing here is
i'm creating sort of specialized
functions depending on what we want to
achieve from the user's point of view
now i'm going to demonstrate when we
actually want to return a value from
these particular function types
okay so for on success what we're
effectively saying here is that
this particular function must be called
with some kind of boolean value
obviously either true or false when it's
called in the implementation of this
particular suspending function
now basically what we're doing here is
when the user updates a single node or
tile in a sudoku puzzle there's a
possibility that that might be the final
tile in the puzzle and in that
particular case assuming the puzzle is
correct and the user has inputted the
final tile that would signal that the
game is complete
so it might be a little bit confusing
here but on success does not necessarily
mean that the game itself has been
completed so that's why i'm
differentiating there
okay now in this particular case what
we're doing is when the user returns to
an active game we obviously want to get
a current game
and there is actually an edge case where
the user completes a game navigates away
from the application and then restarts
the application and so that's why we're
still passing in that is complete flag
here we're going to return obviously a
settings object
let's create another interface
and it's going to be called i game
data
storage and that's obviously an
interface
now before we write the interface itself
we're going to do something a little bit
different we are going to create a
result wrapper or well let's just say
it's inspired by an either monad from
functional programmers but no one really
cares what functional programmers think
or talk about
anyways sealed classes are truly one of
my favorite simple features of the
kotlin programming language it allows us
to create a restricted set of types and
those types can contain particular
values and basically what this will do
and as we'll see in a moment is it
allows us to return an object from a
particular function of i game data
storage and this particular object is
capable of representing multiple
different states so like i showed you
before in igame repository here we're
representing an error state and a
success state as two separate function
references in this example we're going
to be representing both of those states
through a single object
now one final point before we move on uh
if you have for example some kind of
situation where you want to represent
just a success case so equivalent to
just returning
unit and on success what you can do is
you can actually just use an object so
you could say like object
on complete etc but we don't actually do
that in this application so you don't
need to add that in
now let's finish off the interface
create another interface called i
settings storage
now we're also going to use result
wrappers here so i'm actually going to
just copy and paste this over
we're just going to rename a few things
okay and now we can rate the interface
one more interface to go for this
package this one is going to be called
i statistics if i can spell it
repository
and obviously it's going to be an
interface
now one final point again is record is
going to actually affect something in
the user interface based on whether or
not a statistic that gets updated is a
record i.e the shortest possible time of
completion for a particular boundary or
size of sudoku puzzle and a particular
difficulty
the common package contains code which
is reused in a variety of different
classes and functions in this part of
the tutorial we will learn about many
different kotlin language features which
are designed for sharing code in an
intelligent and efficient way
topics covered include extension
functions and properties abstract
classes the open closed principle
object singleton and co-routine
dispatchers
before we write the code let's talk
about the open closed principle
the ocp is a relatively confusing
concept but i will try to explain it in
the clearest way i can
to give you my own verbal definition
which will break down later any commonly
reused software entity which is expected
to change should have a fixed public
interface and a way to change its
implementation
in order for that particular definition
to make sense there's a couple things
that i need to unpack
firstly when i say software entity i'm
generally speaking about a class or a
function but it could be a few other
things
so let's examine what i mean by public
interface and why i argue that it should
be fixed if it's commonly reused by
public interface i am not speaking of a
java or kotlin interface specifically
instead i mean any publicly visible
aspect of a class or a function
since this is an android tutorial let us
take the example of the activity class
an activity fits my requirement of being
commonly reused and expected to change
over time so it is a perfect case to
think about the ocp
every subclass of activity must include
the oncreate function which is a part of
the public interface which it makes
available to classes which reference it
the reason why we want this public
interface not to change is very simple
suppose that the android platform
developers suddenly decided to deprecate
and remove saved instant state bundles
from all lifecycle functions
because this public interface is used by
pretty much every android program around
this platform update would break
everyone's code
what i mean specifically is that all
activity subclasses in all code bases
which have not removed this parameter
would not be able to compile
so this is why i am talking specifically
about commonly reused software entities
like activity and why it is important
that their public interfaces change as
little as possible
since we've established why fixed public
interfaces are really important the next
question is simple how do we then
provide a mechanism or way for the
implementation of the public interface
to change
well it turns out that kotlin gives you
many options to solve this problem
rather than explain them all verbally i
will teach you how to use them in code
as we build this application
right click on the common package and go
to new column filer class
and this is actually going to be an
abstract class which they don't give an
option for here so what we're going to
do is type in base
logic
we will add in the abstract keyword
unfortunately i don't have the time to
explain the difference between an
abstract class an interface and plain
old inheritance in this particular
course this is something i go into and
explain very clearly in my other video
courses but what i will do is explain
why we're using an abstract class here
instead of an interface
the reason why we would want to use an
abstract class is for situations when we
want to share behavior so for example
we'll be writing a
function stub or abstract function which
i want to be shared across any class
which inherits from baselogic and i also
want to share a variable but this
particular variable will have to be
protected as opposed to public and if we
were to try and do this using an
interface then necessarily that
particular value would be public we're
also going to use a generic type so i'll
show you how to do that
so the syntax for a generic type is to
just use angle brackets and then you
could type
quite literally whatever you wanted
between those angle brackets but my
suggestion to you is to not use
something which is already used
hence why i'm using this all capitals
event
now if it doesn't make sense what we're
doing here
it will make more sense when we write
the classes which inherit from base
logic let's go ahead and finish this off
to briefly explain the intent of this
abstract class
basically i'm saying that i want a set
of classes the ones which will inherit
from baselogic
all of which will have this function on
event in other words these classes will
handle events from the user interface
and then as we'll see we're going to use
this job object which comes from the co
routines api as a way to cancel child
co-routines and also to make each of
these logic classes as its own
co-routine scope i'll explain that when
we get to that particular part of the
tutorial
right click on the common package and
create a new kotlin file which is just
going to be a plain old file and it's
going to be called extensions
kotlin's extension functions and
extension properties are among my
favorite features of the language as a
whole
without getting too technical here
extensions allow you to employ the open
closed principle which states that
software entities should be open for
extension but closed for modification if
that doesn't make sense don't worry
about it is it's kind of a confusing
definition but it allows us to add new
functionality to existing source code
without having to modify the original
source code
now this particular file extensions.kt
is kind of like a replacement for static
utilities that we might have used in
java or something like that it's really
just a place where i stick utility code
which is used across the application
let's write our first extension function
to see how this works
the purpose of this particular extension
function obviously it will be used
within activities is really just
syntactic sugar it's a way to make it so
that i don't have to type out toast.make
text and supply this message
toast.length long and dot show
instead in the activity where we'll be
using activities i should say where
we'll be using this particular extension
function we can just type make toast
give it whatever string we want to
display and it's handled like that
by making it an extension function of
the activity class i can use it
seamlessly in any activity
let's write another much uglier utility
extension function
so
the purpose of this ugly little function
here is to take the elapsed time of the
given puzzle which the user is currently
working on and to attempt to convert it
into a value based on
minutes and seconds or a string to
display based on minutes and seconds now
if it takes the user longer than an hour
then we end up just displaying like a
generic more than 5959 now if you think
this code is ugly in kotlin i challenge
you to write it in java
now for beginners this might not make
sense intuitively but it's important to
understand what this is referring to
this is actually referring to the long
object which we will be calling dot to
time on
that might make a little bit more sense
when we actually get to using this
particular extension function
there's only one more extension we need
to add and it's actually going to be an
extension property this time
so what i'm doing here is i'm hitting
alt enter on this particular red thing
and then i'm going to hit add remaining
branches
i'm going to hit alt enter again to
import r
these are obviously string resources
that's one thing we're not going to be
writing by hand so hopefully what you've
done is you've gone and grabbed the
source code for the starting point which
includes things like string resources
right click on the common package again
and we're going to create a new kotlin
interface which is going to be called
dispatcher provider
this interface is very small what we'll
do is we'll write the code and then i'll
briefly explain what it does
now unfortunately i can't briefly
explain what a coroutine context is but
i can't explain the purpose of this
particular class and how we're going to
be using these co-routine contexts
so in most situations most of the work
that we're going to be doing within co
routines land is going to take place on
the main thread or the ui thread now
with that being said there are a few
operations like writing to a file which
we don't actually want to occur on the
main thread and that would be a
situation where we're going to provide
the i o context
now the actual purpose of this
particular interface is really key here
what we're going to be doing is that if
we wanted to hypothetically test any
class which needs to use these
co-routine contexts
in a
jvm environment so not an actual running
application then what we could do is we
could return a particular kind of
co-routine context which allows us to
test in that particular environment i
know that's a lot of technical detail
but i can't really make it a whole lot
simpler than that
however
by using this interface here when we
want to use our coroutines in the
production environment we can provide
the real
ui main thread context
for the front end and then we can
provide a real dispatcher for the
i o thread
to make that even simpler we're really
just making the code easier to test
right click on the common package go to
new
kotlin and filer class this time it's
going to be an object and hopefully i
can spell this right production
dispatcher provider
again what we'll do is we'll write the
code here and then i'll explain how it
works afterwards
i'm going to hit alt enter again
and this is where we will return the
actual dispatchers that we'll be using
in production as per the name of this
particular object
now there's a number of reasons why i'm
using the object keyword here so
basically objects in kotlin are in this
particular case singletons so that
basically means that we will only ever
have one of these production dispatcher
provider
software thingies floating around in
memory space at one particular time
they're also thread safe which is
important because although a co-routine
is not necessarily a thread our
dispatchers.main and dispatchers.io has
something to do with threading and the
other thing that an object can do is it
can actually inherit from an interface
now we're not actually going to be
writing any unit tests in this
particular application which require the
dispatchers but just to show you what
you would do if you wanted to unit test
some class which needs to use these
co-routine context what you can do is
you can just instead return dispatchers
dot
unconfined and then you would return
that for both the i o context and the ui
context and then that is what you would
use in like a jvm junit test environment
the persistence package contains classes
and functions which have the role of
persisting or storing data beyond the
life cycle of an android process if you
don't know what a process is it simply
means a program which is running on a
device practically speaking we will
store the progress which the user has
made in the current sudoku game as well
as the settings for that game and the
user's personal records or statistics as
i call them
here's a quick look at the architecture
of the persistence package the game
repository in this situation functions
as a back-end decision maker for the two
data sources which it coordinates
the data sources themselves just try to
carry out crud operations create read
update delete and either report with a
success or a failure if an exception is
thrown
the general principle here is to keep
things together which makes sense to be
kept together to separate what doesn't
need to be kept together and to also use
an abstraction or an interface in any
place where the implementation might
change i might decide to stop using the
local file storage or proto data store
so hiding these details from the
repository is not over engineering but
rather a calculated decision
speaking of data sources or storage
mechanisms we will use two different
mechanisms for storing our data firstly
we will store the user's preferred game
settings and their personal statistics
in proto datastore datastore provides a
lightweight and efficient way to store
this kind of data using protocol buffers
protocol buffers is a serialization
language similar to json
however i find it easier to read than
json and fortunately the library we will
use also comes with its own protobuf
compiler that will generate some of the
boilerplate code which we would
otherwise need to write ourselves we
also use the device's file storage to
store the progress of the user in the
currently active game
every android app is given some memory
space to store files which is what we
will use
this is done by making all of the domain
models implement serializable and using
java's input and output streams to read
and write objects from kotlin language
so in case you aren't following along
with the tutorial and you haven't
downloaded the starting point repository
what you're going to want to do is
you're going to want to add a directory
called proto in the main source set the
starting point repository should already
have that directory so just go ahead and
right click on it and go to new file
and this file is going to be called game
underscore settings dot proto and make
sure it's all lower case
go ahead and type this in the top of the
file
so protocol buffers are essentially like
a serialization language it's very
similar to json um if you want to look
more into it you can about what the
benefits and the pros and cons over
using something like json but personally
this being the only project that i've
used protocol buffers in so far i'm
quite happy with it
okay so let's just add two more lines
and i'll explain some more from there
okay so we'll talk a little bit more
about this in a moment but basically
what's going to happen here is we're
going to define this uh protocol buffer
message as it's called which is kind of
like a data type for lack of a better
term
and what we can do is uh so this file
will be consumed by something called the
protocol buffer compiler and in this
case what we're basically telling it is
that we're going to be generating java
files now in the generated class files
uh the protocol buffer compiler is going
to basically add whatever we put in the
java package as the package for the
generated java class file it's just
useful to not mix up your name spaces
and stuff like that and as for the
second option here java multiple files
if you don't have that turned on then
what can happen is that basically the
generated java files will all be in one
single file
we don't really want that although i'm
not sure if it's absolutely integral to
getting this application to work like i
say we're gonna go through this pretty
practically and i'm not an expert in
protocol buffers okay now we're going to
define a message which is kind of like
one of the main data types for lack of a
better term in this particular language
okay so let's talk about what we just
did here so we've defined a message
which in protocol buffers is is kind of
like a data type or a collection of
fields and we've done two things so
within the game settings message we have
a 32-bit integer so like kind of a
smaller integer
to represent the boundary of a sudoku
puzzle so when i say boundary i mean
like a 4x4 sudoku puzzle
will have a boundary of four a nine by
nine sudoku puzzle will have a boundary
of nine obviously and the other thing we
did here is we defined an enum in
protocol buffers now when you're
creating these enums you'll need like a
default value
unknown and then you've got the other
values that the enum can potentially be
also notice how
in boundary and difficulty the fields
above the enum i'm giving it default
values naturally those will be like the
values that the protocol buffer gets
pre-loaded with like the first time you
access it
now the important thing to understand
here is that assuming you've added the
support for protocol buffers into your
build gradle configuration the
protobuffer compiler is going to
actually generate some java files or
classes
out of this particular message
okay so what i'm doing here is i've
opened up the completed project and i'm
just having a look at the file which was
generated by the protocol buffer
compiler and all i really want you to
notice here is that when you're using
proto datastore what's going to happen
is it's actually going to generate a
java class for you obviously you can see
we have our game settings in camel case
which is what we defined as our message
and then we also have that enum defined
below so what does this actually do for
us basically this is going to allow us
to serialize or basically translate from
java into the protocol buffer language
and vice versa and it also means that we
don't actually have to create our own
plain old java object in order to do
that the library is going to generate
that for us but we can still use it in
our code which we'll do in a moment
we're going to add one more proto file
so go ahead and open up the proto
directory right click
again go to file and this one's going to
be called user statistics
dot protocol
all right so i've just copied and pasted
the first three lines from the other
proto file because we'll be reusing them
and we are going to create another
message here now when i say statistics
this is kind of like my way of talking
about the user's personal records so
what are the shortest times to
completion
that a user has
made in solving a particular size and
difficulty in a particular sudoku puzzle
it's pretty straightforward so let's
just write it out
and there you have it now you might be
wondering why i'm using 64-bit integers
here so these actual values are going to
be stored in milliseconds which is why i
do want the 64-bit uh integer storage
there instead of the 32-bit integer i'm
not actually 100 sure if that's
necessary but i did that just to be safe
and realistically it's not really going
to eat up that much extra memory okay so
that's it for our protocol buffer files
now we're going to have to create some
protocol buffer data stores which is how
we're actually going to create and
access our protocol buffers
go ahead and right click on the
persistence package go to new kotlin
filer class and this is just going to be
a file called data stores
okay so before proceeding you're going
to want to go to build and make project
now the build will probably fail but all
we really wanted to do is to generate
the appropriate
java class out of the protocol buffer
but if for some reason that doesn't work
for you
just follow along and eventually it will
work
okay so for each protocol buffer based
data source we're going to need to
provide a way to get a hold of it or
create it from
context then the other thing we'll need
is a serializer
go ahead and import everything
and there's two things we need to add
into the delegate here
okay so don't worry that it's showing up
red we'll actually write this serializer
next so i just wanted to explain what's
going on here so we're creating a
datastore object and it takes the
protocol buffer generated java class
which is called game settings and
essentially what this does is it creates
a reference which which we can use to
either store or retrieve our protocol
buffer now you might be wondering what
game underscore setting dot pb is and
why it has a different file extension
than our proto files to the best of my
understanding
game underscore settings.pb is something
that's generated after the fact by the
compiler whereas the protofile is
something we write for the compiler to
consume but in case i'm wrong on that
then feel free to flame me on twitter
the other thing we'll need is a
serializer which takes care of
serialization quite obviously
after that you can just click here hit
alt insert
override methods and we only need the
methods from the serializer interface
so again let's write the code and then
i'll explain what i need to explain
after the fact
okay so i'm going to keep the details
here pretty light so obviously when we
create our data store it's given the
game setting serializer here and what
the serializer does is it helps us to
read and write from input streams so in
other words we're going to be obviously
reading from a protocol buffer file and
then that's going to be serialized or
rather deserialized into java and vice
versa so basically what the android team
has done for us here is they've made it
a lot easier to handle things like error
handling and dealing with input streams
because if you've ever worked with input
streams in java then you can tell
there's you know you're probably
familiar with a lot of boilerplate code
to do with that so basically we do a
little bit of boilerplate work here and
it translates to a very simple api when
we actually want to read and write with
this particular tool in the back end
which we'll be doing in a moment
okay now obviously we need to write
another datastore and also serializer
for the other data type so this is going
to be one of those rare scenarios where
i do actually just copy and paste
because there's absolutely nothing new
we're just going to change a couple of
the words so this would be one of the
points where i encourage you to have the
complete source code open
on the side and then that way you can do
a little bit of copy paste action like
i'm going to do now and that is our data
stores file complete now obviously if
you had a whole bunch of these you would
probably want to use separate files but
since i only have the two i just decided
to stick them in the same file
right click on the persistence package
and go to new kotlin class
this one's going to be called local game
storage sample
so firstly we're going to make a
constant which will represent the name
of the text file that we will be reading
and writing the game data to
next we'll create the constructor
so you might be wondering where file
storage directory comes from when we
create the build logic of this
application which is kind of like my
inversion of control dependency
injection type stuff what's going to
happen is we're going to call this one
function to the android system which
will return us the specific directory
from the system where we can read and
write things like files let's go ahead
and implement the interface
now i'm going to try to get through this
relatively quickly but one thing i want
to explain is that you'll notice i'm
making fairly extensive usage of helper
functions the reason for that is just to
avoid writing redundant code also as
with the other implementations we're
going to be using the with context
coroutine builder to do this kind of io
work off of the main thread
so what we'll do is we'll call a helper
function called update game data and
we'll pass it in the game data
and if that operation happens to be
successful then we'll actually just
return the same game object that was
passed in because it should be
consistent
okay now we can create the helper
so here we're going to throw the
exception so that it'll actually get
picked up by the catch block in the
functions that we'll be calling this
helper
now we're going to be using input and
output streams which are part of the
java standard library in order to write
our data to and from the file
if you're wondering kind of what this
word stream means
ultimately what we're actually doing
kind of at the low level is we're going
to take our uh game or sudoku puzzle
object and we're going to serialize it
into basically a stream or a very long
sequence of textual characters and
that's what we'll actually be reading
and writing from the file
okay so two points you always want to
close your streams also you might be
wondering how is it that we can say dot
write object and pass in our sudoku
puzzle well let's just check the
parameters here so i'm going to hit
control p within the parameter brackets
and as you can see
it accepts any type now the important
thing is that if our different classes
like sudoku puzzle and sudoku note did
not extend serializable then we wouldn't
be able to do this without errors
so for update note it's a little bit
different we're just updating one
individual node so how this is going to
work is we're going to get the old data
and then we're just going to update that
if individual node and then we will
rewrite the result back to storage
so get game will be another helper we
write and what i'm going to do is i'm
actually going to write that one right
away otherwise the auto complete and
error handling stuff will be all over
the place
okay that's what we need to do there
now just a quick reminder here when we
say color and really whenever anyone
talks about a color in a graph data
structure they're really just talking
about a number
so in this case the number represents
the actual value placed in a particular
sudoku square so it'll be like something
from one through nine or one through
four depending on the boundary of the
sudoku
we'll also update the elapsed time
after it's updated we will write that
result
to storage hopefully
and just to keep the front end
synchronized with everything else then
we will return that same game object
now it has just come to my attention
that i have forgotten to add a
particular integer called color to this
particular function when i wrote it so
let's just go ahead and fix that now
there we go
and i managed to save the easiest for
last
and that's it for this file
right click on the persistence package
go to new
kotlin class this one's going to be
called game
repository impul
so in case you jumped ahead and you
aren't actually familiar with the
repository pattern i actually already
explained that in part two of this
series where i built the domain package
in any case let me just reiterate what
the purpose of this particular class is
it's basically like a bridge and
decision maker for the back end now
sometimes you'll have multiple different
repositories or data sources in the back
end and it might be a good idea to keep
them separate the reason why i didn't in
this particular case is because the game
storage and the settings storage are
actually inextricably linked they are by
nature closely related
so based on that and the fact that this
isn't actually a very large application
i chose to put them together within this
repository and then how it'll work is
that the repository will coordinate
these two different data sources
let's start with the constructor
and the repository interface
okay so as you can see we have our work
cut out for us so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to try to write the code
relatively quickly and after it's
written i'll explain what it does
so there shouldn't be anything new in
this particular function except for the
fact that we're making an assignment
statement within a control statement val
current game result equals etc we're
allowed to do that because kotlin is a
beautiful and idiomatic language
this one's actually pretty simple
you know for the life of me i don't
understand why it keeps putting on air
on top
i'll explain this function in a moment
so puzzle is complete is actually a
function which exists in the computation
logic package which we'll be writing
later on of course
and all it does is exactly what it says
but it will return either a true or a
false based on whether the puzzle is
complete or not hence is complete
okay so what i've done here is i've
copied and pasted in the plain language
use case which describes this particular
function
now as you can see it's pretty
complicated to give a basic explanation
of what's going on and why i did this
when we request the current game i.e
when the application starts up there's a
number of different things that could
happen so for starters the user could
have a currently active game and they
just want to retrieve it
it could be the first run of the
application so no game currently exists
in storage and then there are different
situations where errors could occur
along the way this is something that
happens when you're coordinating
multiple different data sources
now i have my own system of tracking
these different event streams i use
basically letters and numbers to denote
steps and different potential event
streams but whatever you do my
suggestion to you is to write this down
in plain language first and then go
ahead writing the code that's what i did
this comment above you see here i wrote
that before i wrote the code
anyways let's get started
okay so for our first event stream we
attempt to retrieve the current game and
that returns successfully and then we
also want to know whether the current
game is complete or not
we can just get rid of on complete
and here we go again
so this is obviously the case where the
user has first loaded the application
and we want to create a brand new game
and looks like i'll have to do this
manually this time
yeah the autocomplete is not helping me
here but in fairness we haven't written
that function yet
okay i'm just gonna double check that i
wrote that correctly now before i want
to move on i want to explain one thing
about my perspective on software
architecture
while sometimes in a simpler application
we can do something like have the
presenter coordinate different
repositories or backend data sources in
this particular case there was enough
complicated back-end logic that i wanted
to have also a decision maker class
which happened to be this game
repository impul
on the back end and part of the purpose
of this class is to take care of the
logic of coordinating these different
backend data sources so that i can keep
the presentation logic class doing what
it's supposed to do managing
presentation logic and then i have this
class dealing with this messy kind of
almost business logic type stuff here
anyways we're not done yet okay so it
just occurred to me that i have missed a
function in the interface of igame
repository so let's just go ahead and
add that in
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to copy update game
paste it down below
and what we're going to call this is
create new game
and it's going to take in a settings
object
and that's it
so that's actually a helper function
that i created mostly for legibility
let's just go ahead and add that in
right now
just another quick note here you'll
notice that i like incredibly long and
descriptive names of everything that's
going on this is largely because i don't
have a great memory for fine details so
by making these things super long and
descriptive i don't actually have to
remember them i can just read my code
and pretty much understand what it does
even in these complicated situations
where we have all these different event
streams and interactions occurring okay
only two more short functions to go
and that's it for our back end in the
top level of the ui package we have four
small files which we will use to create
and apply styles colors fonts and so on
one of those files is the global theme
for our application and i will show you
how to create both a light and dark
theme for the app in only a few extra
lines of code
stay tuned for the end of this section
as i will do a live demo of the
different themes
right click on the ui package and create
a new kotlin file which is going to be
called
color.kt
this file will essentially be a
replacement for colors.xml if you're
used to working with the old resources
system which was based in xml
let's create a color object
make sure you import the compose color
class
okay so before we proceed the most
important thing to understand here is
how to read these particular values so
the first two characters here zero x
this basically tells the compiler which
is the program that will be reading this
code that this is in fact a hexadecimal
number
the second two digits here indicates the
alpha value as a percentage alpha is
another way of saying transparency or
how opaque something is
the remaining three pairs are the red
blue and green or rgb values again in a
hexadecimal percentage
and that's pretty much all there is to
know about these different color values
i've copied and pasted over the rest of
the values because there's absolutely no
point in either of us typing all this
out but also keep in mind that they have
some predefined values such as black for
example which you can also make use of
right click on the ui package and we're
going to create another new kotlin file
and this one's going to be called shape
so in the old view system when you
wanted to do something like creating a
background with rounded corners or a
button or widget or something like that
you had to create usually something
inside of the drawable folder which was
xml based again since this is composed
we can just go ahead and do that in
kotlin instead
and we'll just use some default
parameters
now this might be your first time seeing
the dot dp extension let's just take a
quick look at the source code so as you
can see you can basically just append it
to an integer double and various kinds
of numbers
the important thing to understand here
is that this basically tells the compose
framework that we want to use density
independent pixels if you want a more
profound explanation of what exactly
those are i strongly suggest you look
into it because it's a little bit
complicated suffice it to say that the
idea here is to allow the framework to
create values for heights and widths and
things like that which work across a
variety of different screen sizes and
form factors
right click on the ui package and we're
going to create another kotlin file this
one's going to be called type
now in case you're wondering when we say
type we're not really talking about a
type system or anything to do with type
theory it has to do with typography or
text and how this text is styled or
presented
so again this is very much the kind of
thing that we used to do in
styles.xml
we're basically going to create a bunch
of different text styles which we'll use
throughout the application and then
we'll kind of see how to wrap those up
in a typography object and then we'll
see how to add that typography object to
our sort of global compose theme
first let's create a text style
sometimes we have a situation where we
want to keep a bunch of default values
but we might want one or two values
which are actually passed in as a
parameter to create the text style
object so i'll show you another way to
create these text styles using a
function
just going to do some quick copy paste
here
and then we can override the color
so again what i'm going to do for the
rest of these text styles now that we've
seen everything there is to see here is
i'm going to copy and paste them over
but there is one more thing that's new
that we need to create in this
particular file okay as you can see
we've got a couple different text styles
here
so the last thing we need to do is
create a typography object so basically
what that's going to mean is that we're
going to assign some of the text styles
that we've created below which are used
in common things like the body text of a
particular feature of the application
buttons titles that kind of thing if
that doesn't make sense let's just write
the code
make sure you select
compose.material.kotlin.txt
okay we're just gonna do two more
all right and the only other thing we
need to do is set up our graph sudoku
theme
right click on the ui package and we've
got you guessed it another kotlin file
and it's going to be called graph sudoku
theme
so one of the handy little features of
jetpack compose is that it is incredibly
easy to create a theme for light and
dark modes as someone who uses generally
speaking dark mode almost always i
actually really appreciate this
particular feature of compose the first
step in that process is to create two
different color palettes
let's start with the light color palette
so some of these properties should
probably be familiar to most android
developers like having a color primary
that's how we used to do it also in the
old xml system with colors or at least
that was a common naming convention
now one thing i want to point out here
is that
there's a degree to which some of these
more obscure ones like primary variant
surface on primary and so forth i'm
really just using those because it's
convenient they don't necessarily have
to mean anything in particular
but the important thing to understand
here is that if there's any different
color between a light theme and a dark
theme we do want to define it somewhere
in here and then use it appropriate in
the composables which we'll be learning
to do later on
okay that was actually supposed to be
uppercase there by convention and also
notice that i've copy pasted over the
dark color palette because again there's
nothing new going on there
the next step however is very important
we're going to create our theme and it's
actually going to be really really easy
here's a little shortcut i learned from
a friend if you want to create a
composable function really quickly start
typing comp and then hit enter
just saves you a little bit of time
now this theme is going to have two
parameters here
so before we write the body of this
function i just wanted to discuss these
two parameters so as you can see we're
actually making a function call is
system in dark theme what's going to
happen is this system call will return a
boolean which will tell us whether the
user has specified if the app is
supposed to be in dark mode or light
mode
and then the content represents
everything that will be wrapped inside
of this theme what's important to
understand here is that everything that
we put inside of this composable i.e the
content will have access to all these
different colors styles and typography
information from within the theme itself
the actual utility of this will make a
lot more sense when we actually write
the composables
just to finish things off we're going to
create a material theme composable
and we won't need the lambda expression
so there you have it it only took a few
minutes to create like the color
resources and styles and typography
information necessary to render both a
dark color palette and a light color
palette for different modes what i'm
going to do is show you a quick demo of
what this actually looks like in an
application
here i'm going to be starting the
application in the light theme then i'm
going to navigate to the operating
system's settings and set it to
preferred dark mode
and upon returning we see immediately
that the application now is using the
dark theme we are now ready to start
building our user interface
the ui components package contains
reusable elements of the user interface
since this is a very small app the only
two such elements are a tool bar and a
loading screen
one of the great features of compose is
that we can make our components reusable
in different ways firstly if a component
needs to be positioned according to
where it fits in different parent
composables or parent screens we can
pass in a modifier instead of creating a
modifier within the child composable
this is worth experimenting with in case
you haven't already
secondly it is possible to pass in
composables as arguments which also
allows reuse and extension of
functionality in this app we want
different toolbar icons for the two
different ui screens and we can achieve
this by passing in the icon composables
from those parent ui screens
you'll see later on how we can specify
and handle different icons and different
click events using the same toolbar
we'll also create this reusable loading
screen and later i will show you how to
animate it
right click on the ui package and go to
new package and this one's going to be
called components
just a brief explanation here i've
adopted this particular convention from
the compose samples repository so what
i'll go into this particular folder are
composables which will end up being
reusable across a variety of different
ui elements and different screens in
this case we're going to be creating a
reusable toolbar and also a reusable
loading screen right click on the
components folder and go to new
kotlin file and this one's going to be
called app toolbar
let's create our functions stub what i'm
going to do is i'm going to type comp
and then the autocomplete will create a
composable function
this one's going to be called app
toolbar
first let's write the parameter list and
i'll explain it a little bit
make sure you select the compose.ui
modifier
let's start by talking a little bit
about modifiers so modifiers are
basically how you can create most of the
style size and position kind of data for
a particular composable now there's kind
of two different main ways to do this we
could of course create this modifier and
use it within this widget but that would
be for a situation when the widget
itself is going to be deciding that kind
of information since we're using a
reusable component here an app toolbar
which we plan to use in multiple
different places
in this particular situation we're going
to pass the modifier into this function
which is a way of basically saying that
the parent composable will actually
decide where to position and how to size
this particular ui element the title is
pretty self-explanatory but what is a
little more complicated is the icon and
again that will be dictated by something
in the parent composable that's how
actually make this thing reusable and
allow it to handle different icons or
different actions when it's clicked
after we finish off this particular
composable i'll show you a quick preview
of the actual icon that we'll be using
so hopefully that'll make a little bit
more sense
the first thing we want to do is
override the top app bar composable
let's just pause a moment and talk about
different colors so one way to solve
this problem would be to hard code some
kind of color in here but in the
previous section of this tutorial we
went through the trouble of setting up
both a light and dark theme
so what we're doing here is we're
actually going to be using a color which
is based on the theme remember in the
graph sudoku theme composable
there was a call to a function which was
is system and dark theme or something
like that and that's actually going to
dictate which color palette we select so
by using material theme dot colors dot
primary it will automatically inherit
the appropriate color based on whether
we're in light and dark mode and that
would be one reason to avoid hard coding
something in here
in this case we have a color which will
be the same regardless of whether it's
light or dark mode
so we're just going to add in a text
composable which is effectively a text
view but if you wanted to add something
like a logo for the application in front
or after the title text and what you
could do is you could add in a row here
and then just add in both the icon and
then the text composable and then you'd
be ready to go
go ahead and import that
this is probably pretty self-explanatory
but when we want to inherit style data
for particular fonts and stuff like that
then this is how we can do it
again this is something super handy and
you only see this in kotlin certainly
not java so what we're doing here is
we're explicitly asking is the
application currently in light mode and
then we're picking a text color based on
that this is really just an alternative
way of handling this conditional ui
logic without having to assign something
to a theme specifically
next we'll deal with alignment
and that's it for the text composable in
our toolbar
so action bar is probably something that
will be more familiar to the older
android developers but basically think
of this as like the icons within the
toolbar
generally they're used for very
important actions in the user interface
like navigating to a new feature
indicating that you're done doing
something and note importantly that this
particular lambda function is of type
row scope so basically what that means
is if you have several action buttons
you can place them within these two
brackets here and they will
automatically be lined up like a row now
all we need to do is just type icon and
then add in the parentheses here and
this is because we're actually going to
be passing this icon in from the parent
composables as i said moments ago i just
wanted to give you a sneak preview of
the icon itself we're not going to be
writing it yet but we will do so later
on the important thing to understand
here is that we're deciding about how to
handle on click and what this thing
actually looks like in the parent
composables we're not actually doing it
within the toolbar and by pulling that
responsibility out of the toolbar that's
how we get the reusability that we want
right click on the components package
go to new kotlin file and this one's
going to be called
loading screen
let's create our loading screen
composable
the first thing we'll need is a surface
so you might be wondering why are we
using a surface here in particular in
this case i really just want like a
space
surface of the ui which has a particular
color and specific dimensions here i've
set phil max height to a fraction of 0.8
f which is basically saying i want it to
take up most of the width or sorry most
of the height of the user interface but
i might want some space for something
like a an ad banner or something of that
nature
anyways i basically want an icon or an
image which is stacked on top of a
progress bar which will be stacked on
top of some kind of like text so for
that kind of situation obviously we're
going to want to use a column
obviously we'll be centering things
go ahead and import that
now i'm noticing it's not properly
importing r i think there's something
within the compose libraries which
basically mimics r so let me just fix
those imports before we proceed as you
can see here i've just copy and pasted
in the r import and now we're good to go
that's our logo
there's our progress bar
okay so you might be wondering about
this painter thing so basically in the
alpha version of compose we had to
specify whether it was a vector asset or
a bitmap asset and stuff like that so we
can just use this generic painter
resource thing and point it to basically
anything in our drawable and it will
actually figure out whether it's a
bitmap or a vector asset
also i wanted to point out the copy
function here
suppose you have a color and you want to
slightly change the alpha value or you
have one of these text style objects and
you want to make some kind of change to
it the copy function is super handy for
doing that
in this part of the tutorial we will
create the event sealed class view model
and presenter for the active game
feature
before we do that let us look at a few
design decisions involved in this
architecture
the purpose of our presentation logic
class which i call logic for short is
exactly as the name implies it handles
the work of coordinating the container
viewmodel and backend repositories if
notified of a non-stop event it will
also cancel all co-routines it does not
possess any android platform code which
makes it loosely coupled and very easy
to test i might also consider reusing it
for a desktop version of this app but
we'll see the purpose of the view model
is also to do exactly what the name
implies it is a virtual representation
of the user interface which the view
observes in simpler terms it is a model
of the view it exposes function types
which is a very simple and easy stand-in
for the observer pattern in situations
where we don't require multiple
observers
each time our logic class updates the
view model the viewmodel will
automatically publish the new data to
the view
another design decision with this via
model is that it does not extend jetpack
view model
there are several reasons for this
decision some of them simple and some of
them quite technical the simple reason
is that using jetpack view model creates
tight coupling with the android platform
and it has its own set of boilerplate
code and dependencies which i'm not a
huge fan of in short it doesn't solve
more problems than it creates in this
particular application and i wanted to
practice creating view models which
might be usable for kotlin desktop or
kotlin js
the technical reason why is that in this
application we simply don't need to
persist the data across activity
instances or process death in order to
have a good user experience instead we
just make a fairly cheap call to the
android file system and reload the data
from there if such events occur now
before you apply that reasoning in every
situation understand that reloading data
from a file system works fine in this
application but should not be considered
a suitable replacement for onsave
instant state in every application you
write if you like viewmodels and
savestatehandle go right ahead and use
it we also employ the strategy pattern
to clean up the interface which our
logic class exposes to the container and
the view each subclass of the sealed
class represents an action that can
occur in the view or container rather
than having a function for every ui
event we have one function that accepts
a single object that can represent
multiple different paths of execution
that's the strategy pattern
right click on the ui package
and go to new
package called active game
right click on this new package go to
new
kotlin filer class and we're going to
create an interface and it's going to be
called active
game container
this word container is a technical term
the way i'm using it here is to kind of
signify something which contains a large
portion of an application or an entire
application in my opinion a container
doesn't usually deal much with the
business kind of logic of the
application it basically just wires
things together and builds things and
kind of serves as an entry point in the
next part of this tutorial i'll explain
what we'll actually be using as a
container but by using an interface here
i'm basically stating quite explicitly
that i might change my mind about what
we use as a container
anyways it only contains two abstract
functions
right click on the active game package
again and we're going to create a sealed
class this time
and it's going to be called active game
event
so as i explain in the above comment the
active game event sealed class
represents every kind of user
interaction of a given feature in this
case the active game feature this is a
very common pattern that i use and we'll
see how it works with our base logic
abstract class which we created in the
common package
okay we are now going to create our view
model
firstly let's create a small little
class here which will be like a virtual
representation of a single tile in a
sudoku puzzle
so obviously x and y represent the x and
y coordinates of the particular sudoku
tile value will represent what we talk
about in graph data structures as the
color again it's literally just a number
i don't know why we need to call it a
color now has focus indicates that the
user has clicked on a particular tile
after which they can click on one of the
input buttons to change that particular
number and finally a read-only tile you
can think of as a tile which is like a
given clue in the puzzle so therefore
the user is not allowed to actually
change any read-only tiles so before we
start writing this view model i just
wanted to mention a couple of things
here
as discussed in the introduction for
this particular section i didn't
actually want to use any of the jetpack
libraries to achieve a publisher
subscriber relationship between the view
model and the view now it turns out that
that publisher subscriber relationship
or pattern is actually quite easy to
implement but in this case i actually
found it simpler to just use kotlin's
function types to achieve what i would
call a poor person's publisher
subscriber pattern or observer pattern
so this really means something simple in
practice although it might look kind of
complicated for those who aren't really
familiar with working with function
types
our view model will possess these
nullable function type references as
we'll see in a moment what we can do is
each time we update the view model from
the presentation logic class we can then
update the view by extension by invoking
these function types from within the
view model now the reason why we're
using nullables here is from within the
view model i can never be 100 certain if
there is actually anything listening but
with that being said i feel like if i
played around with this particular class
for a couple of hours i could probably
streamline a little bit and maybe make
some of these internal variables private
or something like that so really what
i'm saying here is feel free to take
this general idea of having a view model
which isn't tightly coupled to android
jetpack but also feel free to experiment
with it and see if you can optimize it
so with that out of the way let's create
some function types
so all of these function types will be
prefixed with sub to ensure good
legibility
active game screen state is actually
something we will create in the next
part of this tutorial so just go ahead
and leave it glowing red here
okay let me just briefly explain these
different function types so the board
state is basically a virtual
representation of the sudoku board
obviously
the content state basically just means
three different states so either we're
loading the data
the user has a currently active game
that they're solving or the user has
completed a particular game we will use
this to animate between different states
in the user interface now timer state
has to do with the count up timer which
basically records how long it takes for
the user to complete a given sudoku game
so just to hopefully clear up any
confusion here timer state will be the
actual long value in milliseconds
representing the time and then subtimer
state is the way that we actually update
the user interface after we update the
new timer state
let's finish off the rest of these
variables
these are quite obviously default values
next we'll write a function to
initialize this view model
okay so let's just pause for a moment
what we're doing here is we're taking
the state of the data as it existed in
storage we're giving it to the view
model and then what we're doing is we're
building the view model's own virtual
representation of that state now the
view model's internal representation
will have things like has focus which
are concerned specifically of the user
interface and not necessarily something
that i would include in the original
domain model
also in case you're wondering the key
value is basically created from hashing
the x value and the y value this is
something that we covered very early on
in this tutorial in case you've jumped
ahead
again active game screen state is
something that we will create in the
compose part of the tutorial
here we're binding that data to the view
model
and then we will invoke our function
types to update the view assuming it's
listening
and that's it for our init function
now we just have a few more functions
which will be called by our presenter to
do various things with the state of the
view model
[Music]
so here we're just updating an
individual tile
so what we're doing here is when the
user hits a particular tile that's going
to send a message into the presenter
which will have a particular x and y
coordinate and then the presenter will
call this particular function and so
what it'll do is it'll look for the tile
which the user clicked on based on that
x and y value and set that one to has
focus equals true and then for every
other tile we want to set it to false
otherwise we could have a situation
where the user has selected multiple
different tiles which is not something
our application is supposed to be
allowed to do
and this would be the situation where
our back end has determined that the
current puzzle is complete
right click on the active game package
and let's create a new kotlin class
which is going to be called active game
logic
okay so before we proceed this is
definitely one of those situations where
i strongly suggest having the complete
source code open on the side while you
follow along here obviously i'm going to
do my best not to make any mistakes but
it's possible that i will make a mistake
active game logic represents the
presentation logic of this particular
feature of the application as we'll see
it coordinates between the container the
view model and then by extension the
view as well as the back end of the
application let's start with the
constructor
okay so just a bit of review before we
move on for the time being the container
will actually be an activity but there's
a possibility in the future i might move
to using fragments as containers instead
at this point i don't really want to but
we'll just see if that makes sense in
the future
but this is the entire reason why i have
included an interface here so that i can
change what's behind the interface very
easily the view model is pretty clear we
just wrote it
game repo is where we store the game
data so that includes the game settings
as well as the current progress of the
user's game stats repo is where we store
the records for the shortest times to
completion of each different difficulty
and size of puzzle and if you're
wondering what the dispatcher is go back
and watch the common package when we
created that we created this dispatcher
provider and i basically explained what
the purpose of it is there
base logic is also something that we
created in the common package
and we'll see the function that we
inherit from that class in a moment
okay let's talk for a moment about
co-routines so one way to think about
scopes whether we're talking about
coroutine scope or dagger or whatever is
to really just consider that it's about
a life cycle
now you're probably wondering why are we
not making something like a view model
or a fragment or an activity our life
cycle class well in case you haven't
noticed by now i don't like any kind of
type coupling to the android platform if
i can avoid it there's a number of other
reasons but one of the main ones is that
because this class contains all of the
presentation logic in a sense it's the
head decision maker for this feature of
the application
then in my opinion it makes sense to
make it responsible for cancellation of
any co-routines which happen to be
currently running as far as this on
event function which we inherit from
baselogic well basically this is an
implementation of the strategy pattern i
won't give you a long and technical
explanation here it's actually a very
simple pattern but basically it provides
sort of like a singular entry point into
this particular class
so instead of having like a single
function for every event we have one
function which takes in an argument our
active game event which is capable of
representing all the different events
and i just find that really cleans up
the interfaces between different classes
interfaces is used in the general sense
in that statement
okay first let's implement our core team
context
remember job tracker exists in base
logic but we also need to initialize it
okay now before you proceed there's
something really important we need to
implement which is a co-routine timer
as i mentioned before the active game
screen does have a count up timer now
some of you are probably going to be
wondering why didn't i use the java
timer class or the androids count up
timer or whatever it's called basically
i did try using those things and they
presented different application breaking
problems and it turned out to be easiest
just to create this kind of co-routine
timer
okay so this requires a little bit of
explanation obviously so we'll notice
two different keywords here which might
be unfamiliar to some of you we have the
inline and cross inline keywords
so whenever you see the inline keyword
the easiest way to understand that is to
understand that it just means copy paste
and if you want to know what that means
in code then i suggest you decompile
some of your kotlin code which uses the
inline modifier and you'll see how the
inline function is actually copy and
pasted into the call site
now we have something else going on here
which is a cross inline function type
so before i explain what the cross
inline action is let's talk about what
this function actually does so here we
have a pretty standard spin lock while
true so it's a loop that's going to just
endlessly execute it's going to invoke
that function type and then it's going
to delay for a thousand milliseconds now
there's a couple different things going
on here number one you have to
understand that we will be delaying this
co routine
but it's not actually going to block the
thread that it's on which is of course a
big win now the other thing that's going
on here is action is going to be a
lambda expression that we will pass into
this particular function
really the only thing cross inline does
is it basically makes it so that in the
lambda function which we will pass into
this function here we're not allowed to
write a return statement in that
function
so in the most general sense here what
we're doing is we're taking a
preventative step to avoid a situation
where we might accidentally return
from within the lambda that we pass in
here causing unexpected behavior
now you're probably wondering since we
have this endless loop going on how do
we actually stop this particular protein
well what we're going to do is we're
going to create a job let's just do that
now
and what we'll do soon is we will
actually assign this job variable to our
start co routine timer and that will
allow us to cancel it
let's just write another quick extension
function to do with this timer business
and then i'll explain what it does
in experimenting with the user interface
how to make the timer the least janky or
most accurate that it could be it turned
out that subtracting one
from the value each time we write it to
the back end created a more consistent
timer but one particular edge case is if
the value equals zero then obviously we
don't want to subtract one from it
otherwise the timer will say negative
one at first and that just doesn't look
very good
okay so with all that done we can get to
implementing the rest of the
presentation logic
okay so when the user hits an input
button we kind of have two different
situations that could occur in one
situation the user has already selected
a tile which would become the focus tile
or it might be that they just hit an
input button without actually focusing a
tile in which case we don't really want
to do anything
okay so if you're wondering about the
details of game repo you can go back to
the part of the tutorial where we
actually build it basically we're going
to be creating a lambda to represent the
success case and then another lambda to
represent like an error exception case
to make that a little bit more legible
i'll just add in a comment here
[Music]
okay so if you're again wondering how we
actually cancel the timer this is
exactly how we do it we cancel the job
object now we'll write this other
function in a moment basically if it's a
new record then we want to render the
user interface slightly differently than
if it wasn't a record
but before we do that let's finish off
the error case
so in order to actually know if it's a
record we actually need to pass the
value back into the stats repo just to
check on that
so i'm going to be honest the error
handling in this application is not the
best neither is it really the worst
show error will for the time being just
actually show a toast message explaining
that some error occurred
okay just a quick fix this is actually
supposed to be elapsed time not timer
state
next we have on new game clicked
you'll notice a recurring theme here
which is that anytime we want to perform
concurrent operations so any time we're
working with the back end we're going to
wrap that into a launch co routine
there's a lot of different ways to work
with cortens this is just one of the
most simple straightforward ways to do
it in my opinion
okay so what we're doing here is first
we're asking the viewmodel has the user
completed the current game if they
haven't we actually want to store the
progress the user has made in their
current game when they hit on new game
clicked because maybe they hit it by
accident or they want to be able to go
back and finish the game or some reason
like that
let's write the update with time
function
[Music]
again we have success in error cases
hopefully that's pretty clear at this
point
next we'll implement that function
next we'll write the cancel stuff
function
so basically the cancel stuff function
essentially cancels every co routine
next we'll write onstart
i forgot to mention earlier the reason
why we had an underscore in one of the
functions for is complete it's just kind
of a convention for a lambda argument or
parameter which doesn't actually end up
getting used in this case we are going
to use it
okay so obviously this is where we start
the co-routine timer and we only want to
do that when onstart is called
now again i feel like i could have
handled this a little bit better it kind
of goes against my rules to consider a
standard flow of the application as an
exception but basically what we're going
to do here is in the event that we ask
the storage for a current game and it
doesn't actually retrieve anything
generally speaking this situation is
going to occur when the user has run the
application for the first time and hence
there wouldn't actually be any data
stored so in that particular case we
would want to do this
now we could also end up here because of
some kind of legitimate exception but in
that particular case i still think
navigating to the new game feature is
still actually a good way to handle that
good but maybe not the best
next we have onstop
okay so onstop is actually tied to the
lifecycle of the android activity or
fragment that it's bound to so when this
function is called that basically means
that we want to save the user's current
progress and then kind of shut
everything down
uh
finally we have on tile focus so this
would be when a user actually selects a
particular sudoku tile
now this function is incredibly
complicated so brace yourself
okay i lied that's actually everything
we need to do
in this part of the tutorial we will
create the user interface for the active
game feature
before proceeding i strongly suggest you
watch my video entitled how to
understand jetpack compose a beginner's
guide to composables and recomposition
we will be writing many composables and
setting up recomposition as well but
that video is made for people who are
just getting started with compose
it explains what a composable is what
recomposition is and how to avoid doing
recomposition the wrong way and believe
me it is fairly easy to screw up
recomposition if you aren't aware of how
it works i will link to this video in
the pinned comment below
this video is full of a ton of
information so please take a look at the
timestamps in the description box below
topics include basic widgets such as
text text button image icon spacer and
divider
layouts such as box column row box with
constraints and my favorite constraint
layout simple transition animations to
animate between a loading screen active
game and a complete game
i also show you how to communicate with
our presentation logic and our view
model using function types and lambda
expressions
before we write the compose code though
i show you how to set up an activity as
a container for composables the process
for doing this is almost identical for
fragments if you prefer them i also show
you how to write a very simple
dependency injection extension function
which hides the back end details from
the front end
right click on the active game package
and go to new
activity and choose an empty activity
and make sure you uncheck generate a
layout file
and this activity will be called active
game
activity
it will be the launcher activity
now in case you're wondering why we're
using this wizard instead of just
creating a class file the reason is
simply that by using the wizard it will
add an entry into the manifest so we
don't have to do that
just to briefly recap the purpose of
this activity here is as a feature
specific container
let's start by creating a reference to
our active game logic class
next let's implement the active game
container interface
i'm going to click on the red and hit
alt enter
for show error we will use the extension
function that we created way earlier on
in this tutorial
go ahead and import
also in case you're wondering this is
single expression syntax here it
basically just replaces the brackets and
return statement with just an equals
sign
next we'll implement on new game click
now obviously we haven't created new
game activity yet so that will show up
as red until we do we also need to
override two more life cycle methods
here we'll tell the logic class that
everything is ready to go
and then we'll also override on stop
and that will obviously signal the logic
class that it's time to cancel things
and tear stuff down finally we just need
to add a few lines to on create
first we'll create the view model
now this is a really important part what
we're going to do next is we're
basically going to anchor our composable
that we'll be creating in the next part
of this tutorial
to the activity here this is also some
something you can call inside of a
fragment
go ahead and import that
and naturally we're going to wrap
everything in our compose theme
now this is a very critically important
thing to understand and a very important
pattern
so when we create active game screen
we're going to pass in a function type
which will serve as our event handler
which is basically my way of saying that
is the way in which we will forward the
events the on click events and stuff
like that that occur in the composable
to our presentation logic class so make
sure you pay attention to what i'm
saying here because this is a really
important part even if you don't use
presenters what or whatever
function types are an excellent way to
handle
on click events especially if you
combine them with the strategy pattern
which we discussed in the previous
section
okay now if you've never seen a function
reference i believe it's called
basically what we're doing here is we
are pointing to the on event function
of the logic class
this really is a function reference so
hopefully you can understand what i'm
talking about here
we'll also pass in the view model
now lastly we actually need to build our
logic class so what we'll do is we will
write that code in an extension function
but what we can do first is just write
it here
and that's everything we need to do in
our activity
right click on active game go to new
package and this package will be called
build logic
right click on that package and go to
new kotlin filer class this is going to
be a file and it's going to be called
build
active game logic
if you've been watching my channel or
live streams for some time you'll know
that i talk a lot about dependency
injection service locators and one of
the things i say all the time is that in
a small application you really don't
need to use a di container
like hilt dagger whatever you can use it
but what i always advise for beginners
is to write the code that these things
generate for you yourself first so that
you understand what these frameworks are
doing for you so that's exactly what
we're going to do we're going to write
the kind of thing that these frameworks
generate for you
and in a small application it's actually
very simple code to write
and of course it's going to return
active game logic
okay let's pause for just one moment
here so in case you're wondering how we
get the path to the storage directory
that we can use for this application you
can call context.filesdir.path
[Music]
finally our dispatcher
and that's all we need to do
right click on the active game feature
and create a new kotlin file called
active
game screen
first let's create an enum
this enum represents different states
which this feature of the user interface
can possess
the actual state is held in the view
model but we will see how we can update
our composable ui by binding to the
viewmodel's function types we created in
the previous part of this tutorial
active game screen represents the root
composable in this hierarchy of
composables it has the responsibility of
setting up the core elements of the ui
and also animating between them
the event handler function type
reference is how we call back to the
presentation logic when the user
interacts with the application it must
be passed down to any composable which
has such interactions we also pass in
the via model which is how we actually
give the data to our ui
in very simple language whenever we have
some kind of data or state which may
change at run time we want to wrap that
data in a remember delegate this tells
the compose library under the hood to
watch for changes and to redraw the ui
if a change occurs
now mutable transition state is used
specifically for animations here so
don't use this everywhere we will see a
more general purpose example of a
remembered state later on
our remember delegate prepares compose
for updates but we also need a way to
actually update the value we do this by
binding a lambda expression to one of
the function types which our view model
possesses
when one of those functions is invoked
in the view model the program
automatically jumps to and executes this
code within our composable this is what
actually triggers the recomposition
we have a remembered transition state
and a way to update that state from the
vo model now we need to set up the
transition animations themselves
this is where you can get as creative as
you like in this app each content state
has its own composable associated with
it we animate between them simply by
changing the alpha value or transparency
now it was showing up as red a moment
ago the way i fixed that was to manually
import the compose runtime
so the transition spec tells compose
details about what the animation should
look like essentially this means we
don't have to write our own mathematical
instructions which is great for someone
like me who sucks at arithmetic
one option for compose is to use the
scaffold composable as a skeleton for
your ui i personally prefer to do this
myself since it's not really that
difficult and it doesn't hide anything
from me
first we have our app toolbar
let's go ahead and create that new game
icon
these icons come from the compose
material library i highly recommend you
use it
this is how we actually trigger an on
click event
as explained in a previous part of the
tutorial by creating our toolbar icon
here and passing it into the app toolbar
composable we make the app toolbar
reusable
below the toolbar we have the main
content of this screen which can have
three different states
each time a recomposition occurs this
when statement will be executed again
the active alpha value will change when
the transition animation occurs thus
fading out the previous content state
and fading in the new one
obviously we'll create these in a moment
and that's it for our root composable
the most complex part of our ui comes
from an active sudoku game a 9x9 puzzle
has 81 different text composables which
is a large number of widgets
the way i went about writing this
composable was to think of each part of
the sudoku game as a particular layer or
element
be sure to avoid writing god composables
by making usage of helper functions
which break down the ui into the
smallest reasonable parts
box with constraints is kind of like a
composable wrapper which gives us
information about the height width and
other measurements we can use that
information within its lambda expression
we need to know the screen width in
order to determine how wide and tall the
sudoku board should be here we ask for
the max width of this constraint layout
here we ask for the max width of this
layout composable but we need that value
to be in density independent pixels and
it needs to be relative to the density
of the current screen as well that's
where the 2dp extension function comes
in and it uses the local density to
determine that value
the margin of the board also needs to
change based on the screen density i
arrived at these values simply by
testing the app on various densities
using the emulator
next we will write a constraint layout
which is a totally awesome way to manage
dynamic layouts
now in order to constrain composables to
each other we need a way for them to
reference each other this is equivalent
to setting ids for xml views first we
create these references and you will see
how to bind them later on
let's create a layout container for the
puzzle board
okay so this is really important see how
we're passing in that reference in the
constrain as parameter there this is how
we actually associate a particular
composable with a particular reference
this box composable will be associated
with the name board
next we'll create the sudoku board
itself
again the boundary is like the size of
the puzzle so it's either a four by four
puzzle or a nine by nine puzzle so
boundary would either be four or nine
this is supposed to say size
so the offset here is used to evenly
distribute the screen real estate for
each sudoku tile and grid line
here's a way to make a mutable state
which is not associated with some kind
of transition animation so this is the
more general purpose approach
so the first argument here
viewmodel.boardstate can be thought of
as the initial value
never equal policy ensures that even
minor changes in the state like has
focus actually triggers a recomposition
again this is how we actually update the
value once the view model is updated
as you can see here again i'm making
usage of lots of helper functions to
break things down
here we render the text fields which
represent tiles in the puzzle they can
either be read only or mutable thus
meaning that we need to render them
slightly differently
so here we're saying if the user sets a
particular tile to a value of zero we
actually just want to render it as an
empty tile
the main idea here is that we're using
the x and y values of each individual
tile along with the offset in order to
evenly position each tile
so when the user selects a tile it's
going to become focused and we want to
render that tile obviously a little bit
different than an unfocused tile
now we'll render the read-only squares
next we'll create the board grid
so sqrt is an extension which is
actually defined in the computation
logic in retrospect i probably should
have defined that in the common package
but it's pretty obvious what it does so
this function here will draw the grid
lines that separate the sudoku puzzles
to make it more obvious to the user
which sub grids are which we draw
different borders to separate the four
by four or nine by nine sub grids this
is why we're using modulo here
so this will draw both the vertical and
the horizontal lines
okay so we're jumping back into the game
content composable to finish it off
below our sudoku board we have some
different icons to indicate the
difficulty of the puzzle
you
next we need a layout container for the
count up timer
let's create the timer text composable
now
for the default value it's just empty
okay we're back in the game content
composable the last thing we need to do
is just add a layout container for the
input buttons
now we're about to hard code some values
in here and that is kind of bad practice
but the reason is that the compose team
deprecated flow row which i'm still
upset about and it worked perfectly for
this situation and i've been too lazy to
implement flower myself
hey at least i'm being honest
in case you're wondering 0.4 and 5.9
will emit a range inclusive of those
values
let's create that composable
spacer is pretty self-explanatory it
just takes up some space in the layout
next we have the buttons themselves
this text button wrapper allows us to
style a nice looking button instead of
just adding on click on a text
composable
all right that's it for game content now
we need to do the game complete content
screen which is obviously when a user
finishes a game
so this is basically just two images
stacked on top of each other but we're
only going to render one of them if it
is actually a new record that the user
made
so since we don't actually create the
emoji events icon we can change the
color of it using this color filter
thing pretty handy
next we have two text composables
and that's it congratulations
in this part of the tutorial we will
examine the topic of graph data
structures mostly with respect to
solving sudoku unlike the rest of this
tutorial which is presented in a code
along format this lesson will be
different instead of rewriting all the
code we will look at the basics of a
graph data structure how i modeled a
sudoku puzzle as a graph data structure
how i created tested and improved my
algorithms to the point where they could
generate a hundred puzzles in roughly
400 milliseconds
before i proceed i suggest you read my
article on free code camp which explains
the fundamentals of software engineering
in a clear and accessible way that
article explains these topics assuming
only that you have some basic coding
skills
let's start by asking a question what
are graph data structures the simplest
verbal explanation i can think of is
that they are a family of data
structures which are useful for modeling
a bunch of things which are connected in
some way to connect that definition with
something visual you can imagine that
the bunch of things are a series of
nodes or points and the connections
between them are a series of edges which
you can think of as lines connecting the
points so whenever i say the phrase
graph data structure a better term for
most people to understand this topic is
a network data structure
in fact that is exactly how they are
used in apps like facebook to represent
users and friends google maps to
represent city addresses in the roads
connecting them or sudoku puzzles to
represent tiles which have relationships
to each other according to the game's
rules
pictures and words are fined but the
code is more important how do we tell a
computer system to virtually represent a
sudoku puzzle this process is more
concrete than you might think though it
helps to be an expert in the programming
language you are using in principle the
process is to take all of the
information you know about the problem
you are solving ie the problem domain
and start writing code which describes
it
first we represent a single tile in a
sudoku puzzle with the class sudoku node
it has a value x and y coordinates and a
boolean to establish whether it can be
edited or not by the user
read only true would indicate a node
which is a given clue at the start of a
new sudoku game now this term color
really just means a value from zero to
the boundary of the puzzle so a nine by
nine puzzle would have the colors zero
to nine to be honest i don't like using
the term color as it confused my hyper
literal brain but please understand that
it really is just a number value and the
term color is actually irrelevant in
this problem domain where the word came
from is that this kind of data structure
was used to solve a problem that
involved coloring different countries on
a map using a fixed set of colors we
could have just as easily associated
these numbers with different kinds of
sandwiches but to the computer it is the
same thing in any case if you hear me
say color just remember it's a value
it's a number not literally a color
now the data structure itself must
include every element as well as the
connections or relationships between
every element
there is no single way to do this but i
arrived at using a linked hashmap data
type from the kotlin standard library
this data type preserves the ordering of
its elements and allows me to find a
specific element based on a hash code
the hash code itself comes from this
simple hashing function which generates
a unique key based on the x and y values
of a node the linked lists themselves
represent both the root node at a given
x and y location as well as any other
node which happens to be in the same row
column or sub grid of that root node the
root node will always be the first node
in the list known as the head element
but other than that we don't care about
the ordering of the rest of the list
so after i figured out how to model a
sudoku game in this way the next step
was to start writing the algorithms to
manipulate my chosen data structure the
first algorithm i wrote was called build
nodes its job was to build the skeleton
of our data structure by adding an
element for every tile in the puzzle
a square size n sudoku will have n
squared tiles or elements so the first
thing i did was write a unit test to
check for that condition
here we see the first example of the
process i used to write these algorithms
i tried to solve the problem one step at
a time and to verify the correctness of
each step as i went
next i knew that i needed to create the
edges or relationships between different
tiles based on the rules of the game
nodes which share a column may not have
the same value or color nodes which
share a row may not have the same value
nodes which share the same subgrid may
not have the same value now we haven't
actually added any values yet but we can
still build the edges of the graph using
these rules
after looking at a picture of a 4x4 9x9
and 16x16 sudoku puzzle i was able to
determine that every tile will have the
same number of edges as any other tile
and those numbers happen to be 8 21 and
40 respectively
at first the test was failing but i
figured out that a node can be for
example in the same column and subgrid
so i needed my algorithm to be smarter
about avoiding those kinds of repeats
the previous two algorithms were child's
play whereas now we get into some more
difficult problems the seed colors
algorithm caused me huge problems and
took many days to get working properly
the purpose of this algorithm was to
provide some initial values ie seed
values to make the next step in the
algorithm easier at first i tried to do
this by distributing the values
diagonally which is a relatively safe
way to avoid breaking the rules but this
approach led me to an uneven
distribution of initial values i thought
this was a problem and eventually came
up with a new algorithm that would make
horizontal and vertical passes of the
entire puzzle allocating numbers in such
a way that was guaranteed not to break
the rules and provide an even
distribution
while i'm proud of this algorithm in a
certain way on a certain level it's also
disgustingly complicated and proved
pretty difficult to test i settled on
ensuring that it wasn't creating an
invalid puzzle and it was allocating a
number of values roughly equal to a
quarter of the total number of tiles if
i allocated too many tiles it would
cause problems though so i had to
include some hard-coded edge cases which
i didn't really like
perhaps the most important algorithm in
this series of algorithms is the solver
algorithm
the solver algorithm takes in our seated
graph and attempts to solve the puzzle
from there
now i had already written a few other
solver algorithms that didn't use graph
data structures so i was curious to see
if using a graph would actually make
this process easier in some ways it did
but it was still overall quite difficult
to write a high performance solver for n
sized sudoku puzzles
every algorithm for generating a sudoku
puzzle that i'm aware of makes usage of
three things
brute force random number assignment
checking if these new assignments create
an invalid puzzle
backtracking when an invalid puzzle is
created or the algorithm is simply not
able to allocate any new values without
actually breaking the rules of the game
the problem with brute force random
number assignment is that it scales very
poorly as the size of the puzzle grows
randomly generating a 4x4 sudoku puzzle
is quite easy that way but even a 9x9
puzzle can take a long time if you just
use random numbers and backtracking
there's no way the app would be any good
if the user had to sit and wait for five
minutes just for the app to generate a
new puzzle
as is often the case the solution to
this problem came from figuring out the
right question to ask
how do i tell the computer to make smart
decisions about assigning values instead
of just purely random decisions
in the end i settled on giving the
algorithm a nice value which is inspired
by nice values in cpu scheduling
in principle the algorithm will select
an empty tile and look at the number of
possible values we can assign to that
tile with respect to the rules of the
game this is done by looking at the rest
of the elements in the linked list for
that tile and seeing how many of them
are already colored that is given a
value in a 9x9 puzzle if eight other
tiles in the list already have a unique
value then the tile we have currently
selected can only have one possible
correct value if seven tiles are already
colored we have a 50 chance of guessing
the correct number which is still pretty
good odds
so the nice value represents how picky
the algorithm is in deciding whether or
not to assign a value
the nice value itself is adjusted
constantly with the basic idea being two
things if the algorithm has looked at
many elements and could not find a
sufficiently safe guess we increment the
nice value thus allowing the algorithm
to make riskier guesses
if the algorithm assigns a value it
becomes pickier again by decrementing
the nice value
the other important part of this
algorithm is the multi-stage
backtracking this part was very
difficult to figure out and it required
trying a lot of different approaches in
order to work smoothly for 4 9 and 16
boundary puzzles i settled on using
three stages of backtracking
in the first stage when the algorithm
gets stuck we remove half of the values
we have allocated to the puzzle
in the second stage we remove all values
we have allocated to the puzzle but we
keep the same seeded values
in the final stage we remove all values
and generate a new seed then reset the
algorithm to start from scratch
after playing around with both the nice
values and the conditions for each stage
of backtracking something magical
happened
i made one small change to the nice
value adjustment and suddenly as you can
see from my benchmark tests the
algorithm was generating 101 9x9 sudoku
puzzles in roughly 400 milliseconds
instead of over 4 minutes at first i
didn't trust what i was seeing but after
removing the change i had just made we
were right back to minutes instead of
milliseconds
the key takeaway is that every time i
made a small change to the algorithm i
re-ran the benchmarks to see what
changed tests are absolutely critical
when you are writing new algorithms as
they tell you both the correctness and
efficiency of your code
i was super excited to have a working
sudoku solver that was crushing my
benchmarks but there was still one more
algorithmic dragon to slay
as you can guess a solved sudoku puzzle
is not actually useful to a person
looking to solve a sudoku game which
happens to be our entire user base
having generated a complete and valid
puzzle the next thing to do was to
remove a certain amount of values to
make the game playable again
at first i thought the difficulty of a
sudoku puzzle was largely dependent on
how many initial clues are given to the
user that idea is true at the extremes
of a complete puzzle or an empty puzzle
but not so true in the middle
what i mean is that you can definitely
have a sudoku puzzle with 33 given clues
that is easy to solve without guessing
and have a puzzle with 38 given clues
that is impossible to solve without
guessing
so i suddenly realized that i was going
to need to invent some way of
establishing the difficulty of a sudoku
puzzle in a consistent way
now i knew that there must be some way
to do this mathematically but the truth
is that mathematics is not a natural way
for me to solve problems i was great at
calculus but only for the reason that i
could visualize the graphs which the
equations described instead of trying to
model this problem in mathematical terms
i visualized the things that i actually
do in order to solve various
difficulties of sudoku puzzles i then
figured out how to tell the computer to
employ these different strategies to
attempt to solve a puzzle without making
any random guesses this led to creating
three kinds of strategies which dictate
the difficulty of a given puzzle in the
basic solving strategy a puzzle can be
solved simply by going through each
square and asking if there is only one
possible value that can be placed in
that square based on the rules of the
game in the advanced strategy we still
use the basic strategy but we also look
for a situation where a node has two
possible values we then look for another
empty node which has an edge to the
original node that also has the same
possible two values
finally we test assigning both values to
both nodes three things can occur when
this happens if both result in a valid
sudoku puzzle this doesn't actually help
much because it's possible to make valid
assignments that still result in an
invalid puzzle later on
if both result in an invalid puzzle this
is obviously not a good situation
finally if one configuration is valid
but the other isn't then logically the
valid configuration is correct
the final solving strategy basically
means that the puzzle cannot be solved
in a purely logical way i.e you must
make guesses to solve it or it requires
some kind of advanced strategy which i'm
not aware of
i'm not an expert in sudoku's but i'm
better than the average player so either
way i would consider that to be a hard
puzzle